breaking news tonight the ccsd school  board is going to reconsider their  firing of superintendent dr jesus jarrah  school board trustee lola brooks tells 8  news now that some trustees are having  second thoughts there will be two new  items at the next board meeting  potentially rescinding his firing and a  second investigating potential  harassment of jara and other board  members duro was fired without a reason  given on october 28th it was a four to  three vote the district will still have  to pay out around a million dollars on  his contract which ran until 2023 he was  staying on the job through the end of  the month the next board meeting is  scheduled for november 18.